[Music]
[Applause]
I'm the one
no I'm not gonna do the Blues Man I mean
these guys I've been singing through
these guys all morning the voice of an
Angel the voice of an Angel Rachel yes
Harriet has a brother left yesterday
when we heard the story about Sinead
O'Connor which is obviously everybody
knows we had a bet when did the song
Nothing Compares when did that song come
out before you Google it can you guess
when that song Come came out nothing I
said 89. I said 89. I would say what
year would you say so so just so you
know Brian said 1990 because it was
their song at the dance school whatever
when did that song come out Nothing
Compares Tom I know this is your kind of
a song when do you think that song came
out yeah nothing compared
1990s when it came out I was in Germany
when the song came out she would cry I
got emotional that song was unbelievable
rest in peace Sinead O'Connor she lived
a difficult life a bunch of stories came
out about her but uh anyways I was
singing the song Yesterday for everybody
in the middle of it while we're doing
graphics people are crying because their
voices like Jesus and Fergie together
yeah it's tough to do but it is what it
is I chose insurance instead because it
was it was more profitable drugs
involved so we got a lot of stories to
uh discuss today uh uh Vinnie is dying
maybe it's the wrong words to use Vinnie
is extremely enthusiastic to talk about
the Kevin Spacey oh my God and quoted on
all counts yeah Hunter Biden obviously
you know would they're doing they
thought they're gonna get to play and
then they called as a staff for very
weird things going on and the judge
finally was like no uh I'm not doing
this you know and they have to go back
Mitch McConnell had a moment where he
froze and some people thought it was
breakdancing some thought it was a
healthy thing some people thought it was
but we can address it to see what it was
I don't know anybody who thought he was
break dancing but the aliens
the analysts I talked to their
underground animals you see the real
stuff I see the underground stuff I
thought he was going to be like you know
uh uh doing blocking it remember that
song Beat Street of course of course
yeah
in fact can you address how many trees
died because of time well Tom every time
Tom does we have to we have our training
machine come out to make the prayers
Three Trees but guess what he has charts
and he's analyzing that's just stuff
outside you don't see the stuff on the
paper look there's stuff anyways China
foreign
minister replaced after unexplained
absence there's some stuff going on
there one in five Americans says they
will never be able to retire Daily Mail
article here's the next one Americans X
expect an inheritance of seven hundred
thousand dollars in the next decade that
makes sense because of baby boomers
Jamie Foxx teases big things coming soon
standoff between Rogan and Trump over
the podcast invite we'll maybe talk
about that uh we got half of the voters
open to a third party we didn't talk
about that last time we have to talk
about the Ron DeSantis firing a third of
its staff uh uh uh after having raised
the kind of money he started his Super
PAC started off with 130 million dollars
and he had another 20 million dollars
everybody said this guy's got all this
money raised but uh Trump did something
in Iowa that's unheard of wait till you
hear what kind of money Trump raised in
Iowa we'll talk about that rates of fed
uh raises interest rates to 22-year high
Tom's got some feedback on it
what else I got here two California
banks merge uh UPS Teamsters they
finally reach a labor deal to avoid
strike hopefully that'll Inspire
Hollywood the writers and actors to
figure it out as well mortgage rates
highest uh Tom 7.9 percent I I think at
7.8 7.9 percent
couple billionaires came out having paid
Epstein 158 million dollars over five
years this is new story something
happened in Temecula where they were
worried about Gavin Newsom finding them
one and a half million dollars so they
finally caved and approved controversial
lgbtq curriculum that's why I think
California's issue is a Statewide issue
uh that they're dealing with and then
this Exodus that California is
experiencing they're saying it's going
to be happening until 2060. that's some
interesting data I don't know if you
guys saw this video of a lady running
around in San Francisco with a gun in
the middle of the freeway shooting
people we'll show you that in the last
but not least market watch owned by News
Corp News Corp owns Fox News they wrote
an article here's the headline why even
confident swimmers can drown according
to water safety experts okay why would
you write that article in the first
place anyways let's go into some of the
business stories that we have here so
fed rates interest rates to 22 year high
leaves door open for more
uh this is a Bloomberg story
um so here we go uh Federal Reserve
interest raises interest rates from five
and a quarter to five and a half heists
in 22 years looking ahead we will
continue to take a data dependent
approach in determining the extent of
additional policy firming that may be
appropriate says Jerome Powell Powell
highlights encouraging signs of
inflation curbing but warns that policy
has not been restrictive enough for long
enough to have its full desired effect
indicating a possibility of further
tightening the fomc upgrades economic
growth to moderate from Modest while
expressing concern over elevated
inflation and service sector categories
due to tight labor markets and expects
credit tightening to impact the economy
following bank failures Tom
wow so we kind of saw it coming got
another quarter point the Fed rate now
five and a half you know it sits here
five and a quarter five and a half
they're sorry it's a little tiny spread
which means it's just putting more
pressure on everything but what he said
was very interesting he said remember
we've been waiting for the FED to
interpret figures well you know we've
been and listen to what does the FED say
that he thinks it's a moderate problem
or a modest problem and we we hang on
the words of the FED but now he's saying
it's going to be data dependent and
number one he said you know inflation
Rose by three percent uh through June
but that was only one month and it was
really like closer to four and a half
and getting down to two percent is a
long way to go and then he said when we
get together on September 19th and 20th
remember this is a longer this is the
longer summer break for the FED we're
going to be all the way September 19th
and 20th before they get together again
and we're just sitting here 20th of uh
July was just a week ago so it's
effectively two almost two months and
what he said was I will have two more
job reports and two more Consumer Price
reports in Hand by that Gathering so
what he's saying now basically is the
stock market is going to be able to
predict and manage what the FED says
says in September because it's going to
be a data-driven approach so we don't
have to wait for Jerome Powell to say I
feel this or you know how we hang on his
words modest moderate major what word
did he use now he's saying it's going to
be data so we're going to look at those
job reports and the Consumer Price
reports if the job report is too hot if
the Consumer Price Index is too high
then he's probably coming with a quarter
point on September but the market you're
going to see the market react as soon as
the reports come out because it's going
to tell the market what he's going to do
because he says we're going to data
driven and I think but that I think is a
sign that things are getting better in
the stability of the economy he also
said I don't really see a recession this
year I think think we've been able to
Surf this thing out a little bit which
means maybe everything the FED did here
even though we had a lot of layoffs
people were looking for work
um maybe we've gotten through this thing
and so I think uh what's a 30 year fix
right now 30-year fix right now so let's
go to more let's say it's like six
points rob you have that I sent you the
link 6.8 watch this what would you
expect would happen overnight with the
rate goes up a quarter point you expect
to be up a little bit it was a link I
sent you from Google on the
in your email
anyway so I just pulled Florida half a
million 20 down state of Florida
mortgage credit score 680 699 that is
where the majority of America is or just
under
30-year fixed
7.95 what
um 7.95 500 000 mortgages 20 down
correct 680 to 699 7.95 correct as of
this morning and you can see a little
Spike up right there that happened
overnight so we're still going to see
we're still going to see those rates you
know between
six and three quarters and seven and
people say well I'm you know people will
write in the comments so I I got a six
and a quarter yeah what'd you pay two
points oh okay well you really didn't
pay the rate but the points just make
your payment less artificially uh
because you paid the points up front so
it's that's where it's going so that's
what the rates are but it's still going
to be heavy on mortgages which means as
we've been talking about homes the
supply is still going to be getting this
pressure well uh quick fact check of
myself the I said 6.8 that's actually
the 15-year fixed uh the the 30 years
closer to the number Tom said in the uh
I'll say to this Tom brought up a good
point you know the whole conversation
for the last handful of months what I've
Seen On The Wall Street Journal a lot of
these papers and on Twitter is are we
preparing for a soft Landing or a hard
Landing in the economy so you tell me
what you guys think everyone out there
watching pbd podcast
I would argue that if you look at the
numbers where we were pre-covered to
where they are today unemployment rate
right around three and a half percent
pre-covered that's right where we are
now inflation pre-covered what one and a
half percent to you know breaking news
if you didn't know we're closer to three
percent inflation if you kind of what do
they do for the Consumer Price Index
they basically remove certain uh costs
of food and goods and energy costs so
we're three percent we were at what
eight percent a year ago so whatever
drone pal is doing seems to be working
and stock market last but not least I
think the Dow just hit the 35-5 I mean I
remember in 2020 when it crashed it came
back I did an episode on uh sawscast
then that we hit 30 30k oh my God here
we go here we go I remember that so
thanks Tom you were my one uh uh thumb
up at that one point appreciate that but
I would argue
tell me if I'm wrong that we're kind of
near where we were
pre-covered
I concur with everything thank you guys
with their constituations yeah actually
um an unemployment does biodynamics get
credit
uh no I think powellnomics credit I
don't honestly don't this is a quick
shout out to Joe Biden I had to do it
because when I'm sleeping here's what I
will say let's be honest he's going to
take credit whether you're deserves it
or not are you kidding me he has to yes
what can the president do the president
has two things the power of the
executive order and the ability to
influence the treasury and IRS on tax
policy has Biden done anything on tax
policy no no has he done anything with
like executive order except for the
Emergency stimulus checks it went out to
all of Americans on covid not really
what has happened us I think the economy
is a little more resilient than we all
and me you know thought and Powell has
gotten things to cool even though it has
stalled the housing sector well the
average president's going to take credit
of course Trump took credit for the
lowest unemployment for the highest
stock market as you should the average
American couldn't pick Jerome Powell out
of a lineup [__] the average American
couldn't pick Joe Biden out of lineup
hell Joe Biden couldn't pick himself
you're Joe Biden and the economy
sustains at this rate or even improves
in the next six 12 months of course
you're going to run on that and say
we're back to where we were pre-covered
elect my old ass for another term and
we'll keep this party going speaking of
pre-covet and then I'll defer back to
Pat to keep going through our stories
here I'm going to Deep dive right now on
return to work who's who's working who's
not and I'm going to have that on the
bizdoc podcast on Monday at 11 30 a.m
but I did see this there are more moms
working now than there were pre-covered
a percent of total moms in America there
are more minority women working now as
total percent than there were
pre-coveted and the survey is all saying
the reason is inflation has pushed them
more of those back to work so we're
talking about the lower part of the
middle class and core middle class more
of those people are going back to work
in response to inflation right now so so
within the victory on unemployment
there's also some pinch families School
women working or new school women who
are like transitioning because you've
got to get that right and the second
thing yeah you know Joe Biden's Legacy
is going to be the man put all the women
to work that's right that's right listen
that's right before I go into this by
the way just let me give you a quick
shout out since you went there in the
reference what did the infamous
philosopher RuPaul say about work you
better work well you better work go to
work working so girl you know you know
maybe that's something anyways I want to
talk about what happened here with UPS
Teamsters do you know what the minimum
wage is now what the average pay is for
a full-time employee at UPS I actually
want you to guess and comment below what
you think it is per hour don't say it I
want you to think what a full-time
employee at UPS average this is what the
debate was the strike they had and they
just broke a year a year ago you said
about per hour what do you think they
get paid per hour matter of fact you can
say per year okay per year and then per
year let me go into it I'm gonna go into
it first so let me go to the sponsor so
our sponsor today is American Hartford
gold again with everything we're talking
about uh the results show this is very
important guys earlier this month the
bank for international settlement
release its 2022 survey on Central Bank
digital currencies this results show
that 93 of central banks are working on
a cbdc 18 of Central Bank said they're
likely to use a cbdc in the near future
and jurisdictions that these Banks
represent 82 percent of the world's
population and 94 global economic output
why is this so important this is
probably the best time for you to buy
some precious metals and set them aside
I own a lot of gold I own it physical
and I own it in accounts and we chose to
par partner up with American Heart for
gold there to sponsor Now American Heart
for gold will ship physical gold or
silver directly to your house or they
can set it up in a gold Ira if you have
retirement funds that you can't afford
to lose now is the time to call American
Heart for gold a precious metal dealer
you can trust they'll show you how to
protect your savings and retirement
accounts by diversifying your portfolio
with physical gold and silver they'll
even send it to you we got some right
here the finest products amazing
customer service and buy back commitment
American Hartford gold has earned five
star ratings from thousands of reviews
and a A plus from Better Business Bureau
tell them I sent you and they'll give
you up to five thousand dollars of free
silver on your first order click the
link in description or call
866-939-6984 again
866-939-6984 or text pbd to 65532 again
text pbd to 65532 okay so UPS strike
just like Hollywood they came up with a
number what do you think is the average
salary now for a full-time employee time
if you read the article Don't Sit
because I know you cheated I saw what
you were doing you're the guy that went
to school you're a
professionals
what do you think is the average pay for
a full-time employee now at UPS don't
say anything Tom what do you think UPS
UPS hey Vinnie what could Brown do for
you give me the answer 55 000. okay
full-time right full time I'm assuming
those people are not minimum wage
average the keyword is average salary
for a full-time you said 55. well I'm a
huge fan of the prices right I'm going
55 1 55 okay well first of all you win
that was not a hard bet two we could do
but I'm going to tell you what it is yes
okay it's
oh my God I can't believe this is it way
higher okay what is the minimum wage
right now Federal in America what's the
minimum seven bucks or something 720.
okay yeah some states want to take you
to 15. okay all right so full time it's
49 bucks an hour that's 100 a year guys
that's exactly what it is the average
full-time employee now at UPS gets paid
six figure salary what that's the mini
let's get out of here we might do it I'm
gonna read this stuff
I'm leaving but hang on
all the haters in the chat that want me
to leave bye bye listen CNBC UPS
Teamsters reach labor deal to avoid
strike okay ups and Teamster Union reach
a preliminary deal 30 billion dollars
covering 340 000 employees to avoid a
strike existing part-time employees
receive the raise to at least 21 dollars
an hour part-time Vinnie part-time is
getting paid 21 an hour while full-time
employees were averaged 49 bucks an hour
current workers get an additional 275
raise an hour per year and an additional
750 hour over five-year contract which
means if you've been over five years the
contract over five years you're getting
paid 57 bucks an hour is what you're
getting paid the deal includes ending
mandatory overtime for drivers days off
and needs worker ratification and
contrast FedEx Pilots rejected a
tentative labor deal with 57 percent
voting against it Pam sorry that I'm on
my phone because I'm just getting texts
from Delhi and everybody in production
they all just walked out
everybody just it yeah so what is the
most shocking thing about this you
thought the number would be way lower
you thought that they they don't deserve
this amount what is it that shocked you
I mean you were shocked I won 55 000. so
what were you shocked about yeah I'm
shocked by the number yes how much would
they have to pay you Vinnie to wear the
brown shorts exactly for truck with no
door and a flimsy seat belt it's exactly
12 times yes can we have a serious
conversation it's exactly two times what
you guessed
okay yeah you said 55 it's a hundred and
one thousand dollars okay give or take
that's average is that factor and CEO is
that fact that's a full-time employee
just 49 bucks an hour that's great
that's insane for this to take place
okay so now you say that's great guess
what it means okay yes it's great by the
way we can make that 490 bucks an hour
what does it cost to ship something yes
okay
you're paying the raise they're not
paying the raise you're paying the rate
so to us if the consumer like let's what
does it cost right now Rob go and see
what it costs to ship uh uh a regular
item just go prices at UPS to ship
anything okay prices at UPS to ship
anything let's just see what it comes up
okay zoom in all right so uh yeah zoom
in if you okay right there so check this
out one pound is eight dollars and 44
cents okay two to four business days two
pounds 9.96 okay guess what now what if
they say well we want wanted to go to
490 dollars an hour we can make that
happen we just got to make it 88 a pound
so this idea of oh day one hey consumer
you lost okay because it's coming to you
in time Tom is a very interesting point
as well for some of you guys that
purchase Amazon what's gonna happen on
Amazon Tom what do we think is going to
happen to Amazon Prime and the renewal
comes to your credit card I I bet it's
going to be up six eight ten dollars
it's got scores how can it not
they have to collect that money from
somewhere it's coming from somewhere now
the difference is the baby business will
go at a loss next year but the
difference is Bezos has fought two thin
nails to avoid Union as much as he can
because he knows what's going to happen
here I did a pold the other day Rob can
you pull up Twitter and go to my Twitter
account and uh you'll see the part where
I pulled uh a union is Union a net
positive to society or a net negative to
society I think around 18 000 people
voted and here's what the results were
it should be the next one zoom in right
there yeah 17 800 voted wow do you feel
unions are a net negative net positive
or net negative to economy look at that
two to one 32 said positive
67.8 percent
said it's a net negative okay so that's
the part about Union when they come in
here's the part
so in in UPS if you were to compare UPS
strike versus Hollywood strike which one
they have to Cave I think it's ups they
have to you have to Cave yeah if 340 000
people go on strike shipments are not
coming in yeah by the way you know who
the number one uh parcel company in
America is right now you know what
number one is no it's ups if UPS missed
this Mark that 30 billion dollars in
valuation goes to whole different place
which means UPS is sitting there saying
guys we better freaking do something
guess what Hollywood is saying fine we
got plenty of old movies yeah we got
plenty of stuff don't do it it's okay
yeah they're still paying a monthly
service while you're not making any new
movies any shows are you still paying
Netflix are you still playing
so the media companies on strike they're
not getting affected but UPS had to
negotiate wow the union had to negotiate
versus Hollywood by Bob iger's like look
it's going to cost a lot of people their
house Hey listen you mother
[Music]
when you think about that part you just
have to know that strike is going to be
very different for these guys than the
other guys but 49 bucks an hour
interesting well and then if if there's
guys you know though we have the whole
conversation about whether college is
worth it or not you know my whole thing
is
typically degrees pay fees skills pay
the bills look there's a lot of people
coming out of debt with a couple hundred
grand and college loans meanwhile you're
just a dude we're driving a truck with
short shorts with your booty shorts
doing your thing open window making a
hundred years
sign me up
movies
all right let's go to the next door 400
years
all right so next so one in one in five
Americans say they will never be able to
retire so this is a uh Daily Mail story
let's see what's happening here we just
went from a positive news of working at
UPS yeah some bad news around the corner
one in five in retirement so Paul by
axios and ipsos reverse reveals that one
in five Americans approximately 20
approximately 20 one in five is twenty
percent fear they will never be able to
retire among them 70 cited Financial
concerns as the main reason for their
uncertainty economic factors beyond
their control let around 44 of
respondents under 55 to change their
retirement plans
44 percent under 55 to change their
retirement plans conservatively
conversely only 36 percent of those uh
over 55 were confident about retiring
that's a pretty bad number right here
approximately 37 percent of non-retirees
expressed doubt that Social Security
would cover more than a quarter of their
retirement expenses reports indicate
that Americans are not saving enough for
retirement with the average balance in
401K accounts decreasing to 112 000 in
2022 down 20 percent damn from previous
year so Adam you see this story what do
you think about yeah well obviously the
401ks are up this year I think the s p
is up what 16 17 so that number's back
up but actually would say that this this
um
article is dead wrong either saying that
20 fear they're not gonna have enough
money to retire and not be able to
retire I would actually say it's closer
to 50 jeez I would actually say that
this number is very low so news flash
only 50 of Americans actually invest
okay so if you're going to retire so
what's associated with retirement well a
retirement account so what's a
retirement account a 401k or Roth IRA
I've been telling Vinnie for about a
year and a half to get a Roth IRA
hopefully they listened up I bought gold
okay good shout out to Harvard gold
Hartford gold baby yeah that's not gonna
that's not gonna that's not the
retirement but whatever no it's only 50
of Americans actually have Investments
um you can't save your way to retirement
you actually need to invest so there's
something called the three-legged stool
I've talked about this before three
legged School of retirement now
typically it's been
a pension where I think the pension
numbers in 1990 35 percent of Americans
had a pension now it's closer to like 15
I don't know that many people the
pension teachers cops firefighters NBA
players you're getting a pension then uh
retirement plans right 401ks Roth Ira's
only 50 of Americans actually have
Investments and then the last thing is
just your personal savings we all know
how people just can't save that money so
it is a major issue in America I
remember when 2016 when Bernie was was
running and he's on all the shows and
I'll do my best Bernie impression you'll
probably do it better Tom do you
understand that 50 of baby boomers uh
don't have any money for retirement and
that's what they're worried about the
word about their health care costs the
billionaires the millionaires the better
that and I was like oh [__] he's
absolutely right 50 of Americans have no
money for retirement don't say
millionaire anymore
that's what it is here's the deal you
know Bernie Sanders was absolutely right
50 of Americans do not have enough money
saved to retirement they should be
concerned I think this article is dead
wrong I think they're [__] uh missed
the Mark here and the average the
average number when it comes to
retirement here here's the actual
numbers
limp yeah you didn't have he didn't say
for retirement so the average the
average American yeah has about 135k
saved to retirement the average American
right but you know a 40 year old if he
has 100 Grand that's right he's got 25
more years to figure it out but the
Boomers were 65 plus right
their average is 225 Grand okay cool 225
Grand do you know what they say the
average American should have in
retirement minimum two million dollars
so you're only 1.8 million dollars off
Carl so it's incumbent on you to figure
out your financial situation because 225
in retirement will last you a couple
years because Americans are living
longer last Point Social Security was
never meant to be a retirement plan the
average social security check is what
two grand good luck getting these people
yeah exactly and they thought the
average uh uh life expectancy was 62 and
a half exactly I thought you'd live
three four years boom thanks FDR Social
Security Boom the reality is you know
you're living to your 89. your Social
Security came out only 5 000 people used
it okay now there's how many now there's
there's going to be 80 million people on
it because 80 million baby boomers five
so the numbers don't add up and it's the
Millennials and the Gen xers the Gen Z's
that are paying into it so the numbers
are all wonky so that's why it's
incumbent on you to figure your [__] out
and save that money in other words
somebody with brass in politics needs to
actually get out there and say guys if
you want to have the future look bright
for your next generation your kids your
grandkids we have to do something with
Social Security and cut it and we have
to do something with Medicare Medicaid
because it's costing us a lot of money
by the way somebody responded here
and this guy commented I want to give
you a quick shout out here with the
comment Chef it's Chef Nick narrow he
says I work for UPS drivers and loaders
they kill themselves daily in the heat
uh humidity cold snow the money is well
earned well Nick I hate to say to you
buddy in the military they literally
killed themselves and they get paid
nothing so this idea about your working
in the Heat and you're killing yourself
it just means how soft everybody is
gotten now if they're gonna pay you the
money they're gonna pay the consumer is
going to be taxed for it so if we want
to start paying this kind of money ain't
nobody if you're gonna say this cops get
killed they should start getting paid
three hundred thousand dollars per year
military guys go give you Freedom they
should be getting paid two hundred
thousand dollars you're 150 000 a year
it's a ludicrous argument but if you got
your money you got your money I'm not
sitting here telling you anything that
you didn't get your money all I'm saying
to you is the consumers are getting the
tax not you we're going to pay the price
for that let me get to the next story
Americans expect to inherit seven
hundred thousand dollars in the next
decade is what they expect to inherit so
here we go
the great wealth transfer will see baby
boomers pass down 53 trillion dollars by
2045 with adults expecting inherit an
average of seven hundred thousand
dollars as a report per New York Life
concerns arise as only 21 percent of
Millennials and 18 of gen Z feel very
comfortable handling the funds with
Suzanne Schmidt from New York Life
stating that they may be more
risk-averse due to economic changes they
witness in their formative years among
those anticipating an inheritance in the
next decade 58 percent expect cash 43
percent anticipate property 28 percent
look forward to stock and bonds while 24
brace for life insurance proceeds in
other words they're waiting for their
parents to die over half worry about
inflation impacting their funds and 37
percent plan to use the windfall to pay
off the debt while 35 intent to
supplement their retirement savings and
26 plan to pass it down themselves I
think after four stats you lost people
but we get the point so what's your
thoughts on this story here no well
listen A very wise man once said look
150 million bucks ain't what it used to
be okay
you know it's not what he used to be so
with that being said 700 Grand 700 Grand
ain't what it used to be inflation
that's a half a million bucks so
um
a lot of Americans feel like they're
going at it alone with their financial
situation we just talked about the
retirement plan and not people
understanding uh the money situation I
mean look 700 Grand is great it's
amazing if you get that uh I'll give you
a game plan in a second but it's it's no
secret that at what 70 of lottery
winners that make that win a hundred
million dollars plus go broke in the
first five ten years okay so 700 Grand
you wanna you wanna go through 700 Grand
buddy come out with me for a weekend in
South Beach yeah bro let me say
something to that look I would love to
give parents a grade for what they
passed down to their kids okay I give my
parents an a even though they gave me
not a nickel my mom and dad both said
when we die you ain't getting nothing
okay but guess what they gave me they
brought me to America that to me is all
the money in the world all the
opportunities everything that is a way
of what you gave to your kids my parents
gave me values and principles now
if you're born here and you're raised
here and your grandfather brought you
they've given their inheritance to you
what are you now doing to give to your
kids that was born here I do feel we
need to give grades to parents of what
they give their kids okay one lowest
level grade C is a what you give them a
place to live you give them food you
send them to public school great that's
a c great that's average B if the kids
uh you're helping with the college
education you do all of that stuff and
you pay for their college and they go
and they do this and they do that okay
great that's maybe a b then if you
provide them all shelter and you do your
best for you and your husband you and
your wife to stay together it's not easy
half marriages end up out of divorce but
you do your best and you help them go to
college and when you die
they get start to buy down payment on
the house maybe given fifty thousand
dollars down payment on a house or a
hundred thousand dollars down payment on
a business or a house and then when you
die they get seven hundred thousand
dollars I have to tell you I actually
plant these baby boomers that are giving
their kids seven hundred thousand
dollars I think I hope that tradition
continues of course we can say seven
hundred thousand dollars isn't anything
today what I don't want to do is you
know how sometimes no matter what you do
for somebody they'll always say that's
it that's it that's it you know that
whole idea like that's all you're gonna
do for me like I remember one time we
went we will give people uh we'll have a
meeting we're like dude this guy's gonna
be so excited to give this guy raise his
attitude is going to be freaking awesome
because you want to give you guys a
raise and I'm like that's all you're
giving me a 20 raise a 10 raise I'm like
do you remember this like I'm like you
know what honestly forget it it's off
the table bro don't worry about it go
look for another place we're okay we're
moving forward but but the more they say
then no problem go no
I say this is not the place for you go
elsewhere
they'll probably go to UPS the stories
very I'm just telling you we've been on
both sides we'll be screwed on them all
I'm saying to you is I want to recognize
good behavior the seven hundred thousand
dollars is good behavior what I'm
concerned about here's my concern I'm
concerned the next generation is going
to be worse than Boomers
I'm concerned the next generation is not
going to leave anything for their kids
of course it's going to be something but
not as much as these guys are because no
one's talking about that there has to be
conversations about what are you leaving
your kids Behind when you're done this
whole notion about everything's about
you you you you me me me me what are you
leaving them this is why I love when I
read Kennedy's Book and I read Bush's
book agree or disagree with these
families they've done well for their
families maybe you don't agree with what
they've done for America maybe you don't
agree with what they've done for you
know uh the world let me tell you
they've done a lot for themselves okay
and one of the Traditions they have is
your job excuse me your job is when you
get married make your money make sure
your wife is scored away retirement make
sure your kids are scored away with what
they want to do with school and a couple
things in the future make sure you're
squared away with retirement then figure
out a way to go back and give to Public
Service choose to make 100 million 50
million five million 10 million 20
million 300 million you're George Bush
going to Texas Rangers do whatever you
want to do but I think we need to talk
about that more and more and more if you
want to get an A I think an a to me
is good values good principles home
standards expectation after school
programs dropping them off driving it's
a lot of work man Dylan goes to three
different sports every day Tico Dylan
every day they're in Jiu Jitsu then they
golf then they're going to swimming then
they're going to soccer then he's going
to baseball then they're going to tennis
I mean you know how many people are
driving these guys around that's a lot
of work so I think I think parents have
to give themselves a grade to say babe
if husband and wife are talking to each
other tonight have a conversation with
your wife have a conversation with your
husband babe what kind of a grade do we
want to give ourselves as parents when
we're no longer here is it a c is it a b
or an A let's figure this thing out I
think we need to raise our standards so
I think this is a good sign with the 700
000 quick quick response to that I I do
agree 700 Grand would be an amazing
number I was being sarcastic when 150
Grand wasn't one of us today yes I agree
um what I will say you're absolutely
right I think the numbers actually break
down to well it's 15 of Americans expect
to receive an inheritance the next 10
years that's awesome 70 percent of it is
from parents and 25 percent it is from
their spouse so the large majority
you're absolutely right Pat it is from
the parents and I absolutely like one of
my favorite things that I that I love
being here with with Pat and
valuetainment it is just reaffirmed
everything you said in the first place
that you gave your parents an a why
because they just brought you to America
with good values and principles zero
dollars your dad worked at a 99 Cent
Store zero but that that to that to you
is priceless and this is this is kind of
nothing to do with the financial
component but it does have to do with
the fact that you're living an American
opponent it sickens me to see the stats
out there of gen Z more than half are
are not proud to be American or or or
believe in Socialism or are basically
disgusted with being an American I think
we have that story Rob and to me it's
just so sad and it's indicative of where
we're at and how divisive we are these
days you know I dated a girl for many
years who was from one London from the
UK and I would go over there every
summer with her and I was the American
guy all the Americans here and I was
like you [__] know it buddy John
Wayne in the house buddy yeah with your
red coat ass like I'm so proud to be
American okay and this isn't a republic
thing a democratic thing it's just an
American thing and to the young people
watching that don't love America listen
nobody's forcing you to stay here yeah
okay if you don't like your job leave
yeah but get a different job okay if you
don't like the city you live in leave if
you don't like the country you live in
get the [__] yeah yeah Adam good good
luck trying to go to another country you
think like other countries are just like
yeah come in try to go to Canada or
somewhere they don't want you they don't
want your ass but we're gonna talk [__]
about it to that point is like when
these people go to a different country
go to the go to Iran yeah go to the
Democratic Republic of Congo yeah like
go to South Africa good luck go to Haiti
and then come back here and be like yeah
I was wrong about that happy to be here
in my house in America yeah boy we went
on a
hey can you guys just I'm curious how if
you're comfortable what amount of money
do you believe your parents are leaving
you behind when the day comes that
they're no longer here can you please
put that in the comment section somebody
said run and pull money is power I'd be
curious to know what some of you guys
are going to say go ahead Tom I have
been saying that uh Adam and Vinnie took
a big old Loop there to the
unappreciative people and I'd take that
right back to the parents part of the
other grade you can give your parents is
what do they teach you about
appreciating the place that you're
living and the opportunity you have you
say you give your parents an a because
they brought you to the United States I
tell my girls all the time I said look
this isn't perfect there's a lot of
debate out there there's a lot of things
going on there's things going on in your
school we're gonna go talk to school
board we're gonna be civil and we're
gonna do it because that's how we do it
in America we meet in the Public Square
we vote or we go into rooms and we said
debate things and we try to do it
civilly some of those don't go well they
end up on the news people screaming at
each other at school board meetings but
you know what all the stuff that's
happened here this is still the best
place in the world to be this is still
the best soil to plant your seed this is
still what it's all about and that's not
elitist that's not Prejudice girls
that's just what Freedom Liberty free
enterprise and capitalism as a
foundation for tomorrow does and I think
when parents don't give a little of that
to their kids about how good you have it
here regardless of how many dollars
you're going to be able to leave them I
think that loses something because the
people you're talking about I agree Adam
I don't use the phrase but I'll
abbreviate it you know
GTFO you know yeah it's a goodbye but
why are some of those kids having that
that thing I think that there's an
obligation to parents maybe also tell
that story too what are the what's
coming up and what are people saying
they popping in let me tell you what
they said so most people Rob would you
agree most people are zero Mo and 90 put
zero one person put 50k one person put
five million I saw one 250 I saw one 500
000 I saw one 1.1 million I saw one 1.2
million in real estate 400 000 online
life insurance 150k 400k two and a half
million 250 600 000. this is why for
some that don't have money the easiest
way to leave money behind to your family
is life insurance this is why we sold
nearly half 500 000 life insurance
policies the last 13 years and counting
yeah and Counting if you can't afford to
do it get them a life insurance policy
yeah get something to leave beyond your
family it's such a one of the biggest
backbreakers of a family when siblings
are left is when parents die and
siblings fight on who pays the money and
the poorest sibling always blames the
richest siblings saying you have the
money you pay for it and
and then there's a division between uh
what do you call it sibling that's the
last thing parents want so if you want
your kids to be United you don't want
them to divide get an insurance policy
protect the family but it's interesting
how most people right now 90 their
answer was Zero nothing's being left
behind wow that's pretty well that's
what is being left behind for them or
that's what they've made my mom and dad
are leaving me zero as well that checks
out because 15 of Americans expect an
inheritance so you know scary thought by
the way because inheritance is a very
very big aspect of what you do don't get
me wrong I didn't start with nothing
there's different mindsets to it but
what if you could what if you could do
it what if we can do it now rather than
looking back and saying well that's the
reason why I'm not winning no you're
just bitching and whining and you're
acting like a victim I don't have
anything and I still went and figured
out a way to win we're still grateful
we're happy all I'm saying is why don't
we start with us what can we do about it
anyway I agree about the life insurance
component if I could just give you 30
seconds have done that if you're a young
dad out there okay I'm speaking to the
fathers right now no I'm not a kid I'm
not a father I plan on being one soon
um
for your young kids if you're a 35 year
old guy 40 year old guy 45 year old guy
you got two kids you're working you
think I'm healthy all good you know
nothing's gonna happen to me you know
what they say [__] happens God forbid a
term life insurance policy by the way I
don't sell life insurance you know what
I do in business
if a term life insurance is less than a
cup of coffee a day whatever they say go
get a 100 000 policy go get a half a
million dollar policy get a million
dollar policy God forbid your P your
kids will be taken care of and then by
the time they're 21 that's cool you
don't have to do anything let's go to
the next story let's go to the next
story let's go to the next story okay so
next story uh uh I want to go into
what's going on with mortgage demand
drops okay we have that we covered that
already we cover that already okay so
check this one out journalists witnessed
witnessed three thefts in 30 minutes
during segment at the most robbed
Walgreens in U.S okay that's pretty wild
when you think about this stuff here
okay Rob if you can pull up the clip the
video okay and what happens I don't know
if you have the clip or not if you do
pull it up while I'm reading this CNN
journalist kyung Lao witnessed three
thefts in 30 minutes at the most wrapped
Walgreens in the U.S while reporting on
the store's anti-theft tactics the
Richmond neighborhood store in San
Francisco has the highest theft rate
amongst among nearly 9 000 Walgreens
locations in the country the store
experiences over a dozen thefts a day
leading employees to use certain chains
to secure freezer sections however due
to negative messaging the chains were
later removed San Francisco Bay Area
ranks as the second hardest hit
metropolitan area by theft according to
National Retail federations 2022 retail
security survey Walgreens has closed
five stores in the region due to theft
and other chains like Target Whole Foods
Nordstrom CBS and Amazon
have either left downtown San Francisco
or plan to do so go ahead and play this
clip
to try to combat theft Arc young law
visited one Walgreens that's hit by
shoplifters more than a dozen times a
day it happened three times while she
was inside
Richie Greenberg walked into a San
Francisco Walgreens when he saw in the
Frozen movie
this change heavy chains that went from
padlock to padlock on both sides of the
door to get some frozen pizzas bizarre
something I'd never seen before this is
just more icing on the cake
telling us that rampant crime is is has
become a regular part of life so typical
that in the 30 minutes we were at this
Walgreens
yeah
he just stole no face no case it's
did that guy pay
no and they don't give it and they can't
stop they can't stop Richmond
neighborhood store with piles of
products like mustard locked behind
Plexiglas has the highest effect rate
can you pull up the other video that the
lady in the freeway is going around
shooting people naked in the middle of
the freeway is that also in San
Francisco yeah San Francisco
this is even more insane look at this
that lady's naked she's got a gun and
she's just shooting it's my ex
China broke up she's shooting at people
I would imagine that's how you go in and
then she runs out of bullets this guy
gets scared recording her so he puts the
camera down
and he's like okay she's not looking let
me record look at her and then boom she
runs out of bullets yeah you know what's
great the cars are going to the left if
someone would have randomly
yeah exactly no I'm sorry if she's
firing at people no no but I would have
flipped that chick 50 feet in here and
then you would have got arrested no if
she's if she's got a gun and she's
firing on people yes you're running
right through her yeah I'm sorry I would
have disarmed her for the safety of the
other motorists but all it takes is one
sorry about all it takes is hers you're
in San Francisco they're gonna say
they're gonna blame you you're gonna be
great manslaughter you're gonna be right
well Governor Newsom put me on trial
yeah I mean trial
thing about it you know what that lady
has rights she should be able to walk
around naked in shoes
in the midst of a mental health crisis
I'm not gonna run her down and kill her
I'm gonna sit there and I'm gonna see if
I can knock her down no no
listen because first of all Tom this is
what happens when you defund the police
when you when you tell the people that
work there you guys can't even try to
stop them when a thousand dollars or
below isn't even a nobody gives a [__]
no zero hold on there's zero security
there it's Catch and Release yeah you
can't you can't and interfere with this
because you're gonna get in trouble
because they're gonna bring up race
they're gonna bring up a bunch of
[__] this is the epitome of what
California is going to [__] and guess
what Gavin Newsom is going to be the
front runner and he's going to run on
what do you mean on the I have the
richest state we're killing it it's a
[__] and I dude like the fact that
they're letting that happen in America
dude there's chains there's locks and
videos
you don't know anything about California
you didn't live there for 15 years oh
you lived there for four yeah you lived
there for 15. that's crazy so you have
experience in this yeah yeah oh I had no
idea what's it like there it's actually
um oh what's that it's a [__] oh and
I actually I've linked up with a guy
named Patrick but David by the way have
you ever lived you've never lived in
California oh 24 years okay how long
were you there oh Tom I was I was born
there oh yeah okay I'm a Florida boy I'm
a Florida man so I don't know about this
so collectively This Is 50 years of
California right the thing about this
Pat you see that you see the crime you
see the the the walking in the street
with a gun you see what they're trying
to put into the schools in your right
mind why the like especially liberals
and I have cousins that are just like
they love nothing they can't admit it
but look at what the hell is going on in
California bro look at what's happening
Vinnie think about it you can Ski and
Surf on the same day yeah you're right
so there you go that's worth
homelessness
let me transition this story there's a
part of this guys this is actually a
serious story I understand we're having
fun with this and this lady's naked
running around thinking she's at a you
know freeway strip club she's she's
she's she's got issues for a person to
walk around naked with a gun you got
issues to do something like that fine
let's set that aside for people to be
afraid to do the natural thing the
natural thing should be shoot her down
or call the cops and even if you call
the cops what's the first thing going to
tell yourself they're not going to get
here on time I mean people could get
killed by the time somebody gets here so
I'm so scared to actually follow the law
that it's better off for me to sit aside
sit on the sidelines but while we're
talking about all of this stuff on
what's going on there
there's a story here about California
where's the story about California 2060
what page is that on there it is okay so
page 16 if you go to it people are
wondering I tweeted this yesterday about
Newsome uh uh people are wondering this
so California
uh where's the store is it 15 or 16 Rob
15 amid California accidents I made
California exit a state population
projected to be the same in 2060 as it
is today okay California's population
projected to stay the same stagnant
until 2060. guys that's 37 years with
estimates 37 years up to 37 years with
estimates showing 39.51 million people
slightly over then 20 20 figures 39.52
million uh the state's population
decline is attributed uh to an ongoing
Exodus of residence with over half a
million people leaving between January
2020 and July 2022 and more considering
leaving due to the factors of high taxes
cost of living and social issues the
decline in population could have
significant impact on California's tax
basis tax base and political
representation with a budget deficit of
nearly 32 billion honors reported in
2023 and the loss of a house seat in
2021 now watch this you're seeing this
at Walgreens the worst in America out of
how many Walgreens was it nine thousand
nine thousand Richmond San Francisco
we're number one you're seeing the
streets freeway ladies walking around
with guns you're seeing what's going on
here with the state of California saying
population is going to stay the same and
then and then they're wondering why
parents are sick of Newsome then there's
this story Temecula California school
board caves and approves controversial
lgbtq curriculum after threats of one
and a half million dollar fine from who
Yours Truly the governor Newsom let me
read this to you friendly people of
California the conservative the
conservative the conservative Temecula
Valley
unified school districts board in
Riverside County California initially
rejected a social studies curriculum for
grades one through five that included
discussions about the life of Harvey
Milk I don't know if you've seen the
images what this Harvey Milk guy did
what he's all about underage boys too
that was his that was his job openly gay
elected official in California due to
concerns about his aligned alleged
inappropriate behavior around teenagers
Governor Gavin Newsom intervened and
threatened the school board with a one
and a half million dollar fine for not
adhering to a 2011 California law that
mandates teaching about lgbtq historical
figures in school fearing that financial
burden of a lawsuit and the school's
board reverse its decision and
unanimously approved the use of the
textbook social studies alive with more
with some modifications to ensure
age-appropriate content okay so here's
what what does this mean here's what
this means let me tell you what this
means you know to all the parents who
are fighting whether it's in Glendale
whether it's in
Camarillo whether it's in La whether
it's in Hollywood whether it's in
Bakersfield whether it's in all these
different counties right Temecula is a
conservative County
Temecula agrees with the conservative
parents and even Temecula being the fact
that it's a conservative County caved
and they couldn't fight off the bully
named governor governor Newsom Gavin
Newsom
so what's what's the next step you have
a few different choices here's the
choices you got a person a parent can
sit there and say the following they can
say I'm not going anywhere no problem
I'm gonna fight this fight perfect let's
process that together
how long is this fight gonna take you to
win five to ten years let's say 10 years
by that time your seven-year-old is 17
they're already been indoctrinated by
that time your 11 year old is gone guess
what whatever indoctrination they wanted
to do to groom your kid Dev succeeded
you lost just so you know you lost so
now what do you want me to do Pat what
do you want me to do you got
homeschooling you got private school or
you got get the hell out of California
Mark Wahlberg who's a Hollywood
Superstar loved by everybody moved to
Nevada okay Rogan moved to Austin musk
moved to Austin because he didn't like
what they were doing to his headquarters
on Tesla you got who else you got
golfers left there to come to Florida I
can't give you a name tiger Phil plenty
of names many athletes quietly behind
closed doors are leaving yet these
parents are sitting there saying no I
think they're going to do this I think
they're going to do this the pain isn't
there yet there needs to be such a
massive listen yeah okay so look what
see look what up let UPS be the
inspiration to you these people went on
a strike with ups and all of a sudden
what happens they went on a strike they
got a 30 billion dollar agreement that
took the average rate to 49 bucks an
hour for a full-time employee working at
UPS the minimum wage
for a part-time employees 21 bucks an
hour three times the national minimum
the federal minimum is 720. UPS got 21
okay California if you truly want to do
something what about if we do this what
about if there's a national strike
with parents you guys do a massive Zoom
together and you do the following how
many of us are teachers how many of us
are good at math how many of us are good
at this how many of us are good at that
take the lead do homeschooling with your
kids create environments where they can
go to school okay go raise money on a
GoFundMe okay and have somebody that's
trusted that we can give money to that's
going to manage this whole thing and
let's raise money and all of a sudden
Imagine School Days August 15th is first
day or 16 by the way we were going to do
an event in Glendale yeah it's so
competitive like some counties and
districts are fighting the other
districts but we're the ones that
started it yeah we're the ones that I
said listen guys ladies I'm not here to
compete if this is about competition I'm
about wanting to do something for the
entire State you guys figure this thing
out if you guys all want to unite let's
come in and fill in a place for three
four thousand people I'm paying for it
I'm coming to you and there's there like
we're coming to you you're not we're not
asking you to come forward I'm taking
two days of my life to come to you to do
this stuff I want to do to help you guys
out but rather than competing against
each other what if everybody unified all
districts and said who cares if your
video went viral mine one more vital
word than yours who gives a [__] right
what if we all unified and we showed
Unity this is why Newsome wins because
if all these districts are competing
against each other new songs like look
at these guys they're going to eat each
other up they're worried about whose
video went more viral while I'm winning
over here and I'm finding you guys and
you guys are caving you ain't got that
much power that you think you do but not
flip it on them watch this let's all
unify Tom what would happen
if day one of school
if all of these parents that are
concerned their kids just didn't show up
to school and not one not a hundred not
a thousand not ten thousand what if
fifty thousand kids didn't show up to
school wow why what if that was a
Statewide message to the entire
by the way to the parents watching us
that are fighting their fight you guys
got some audacity courage I salute you
yep for what you're doing at the highest
level the ladies I spoke to there was a
couple of these ladies I'm like oh my
God I love her fight man she's a boss
she's a dog she's a she's a competitor
I'm loving that the way but but ladies
gents come together all districts your
enemy is not another District that's
doing a better job than you on their
Instagram account yeah what if you all
come together okay and you show 10 20 50
100 000 let me tell you why this is your
time to do it let me tell you you got
three weeks by the way to be thinking
about this together
let me tell you why this is a time to do
it you know why this is a perfect time
to do it what does Newsome want to do in
the next 12 months he wants to be the
president he wants to be the president
and who is his biggest enemy he's
targeting and Bastion on a weekly basis
wrong well guess what governor Newsom
if parents
fathers mothers pastors Priests of
Catholic Church
if you guys come out together
in front of his office in Sacramento I
don't know you guys all roll up do it in
front and you do this for four five six
ten fifteen twenty days you can afford
30 days and by the way some of you guys
I got kids that are six years old 10
years old 12 years old if these kids 10
time when does GPA really start
mattering for college 9th grade or tenth
grade uh you know eighth to ninth you
start now it really really matters when
do colleges start looking at your GPA to
determine like will they say you had bad
grades in eighth grade and we're not
going to accept you the body of work
starts in ninth grade and if those kids
have a weak Middle School ninth grade
always sucks okay so let's just say
ninth grade you know what that means
they're targeting kids that are in first
grade second grade third grade fourth
grade all of them you know what this is
gonna sound crazy to me if my kid
doesn't go to school for a month and
it's in sixth grade and I can fight to
protect my kids from being taught these
nonsense videos of this is normal a boy
giving another boy a [__] and I'm
sorry man I'm gonna take my kid out for
a month and I'm gonna rally thousands of
other people to do the same hey Newsome
what do you want to do about it problems
in your state homeboy what are we doing
about it now now we got national
attention now everybody is talking about
it now he has to do something and he
can't go around threatening a
conservative Community like Temecula to
say one and a half million out of fine
with their corner to have to Cave
because what are they going to do these
school districts don't have a lot of
money no we have to pay that one and a
half million dollars which is why
they're against vouchers because you put
the voucher in the hand of the parents
School vouchers Pat you see what happens
I'm pulling my kids I'm pulling this it
moves the it puts the economic power
with those parents I vouchers and by the
way every you know again it was such a
weird dynamic when I talked to all of
them
everybody I spoke to a different School
District everybody in one way or another
would throw a comment of you know we're
the first ones that did this right yeah
you know what the first ones that did
this right you know where the first this
I'm like I'm like guys honestly I don't
care I went to Glendale that's my pride
and joy because I went to that school I
got great memories there but Glendale
ain't gonna change [__] alone because
the guy that's running the whole thing
is a governor you got to get his
attention and to get his attention we
got to get a hundred districts 50
districts to come together and if you do
you make that kind of a noise during
election year forget it Joe's calling
saying hey Governor Newsom what are you
doing to fix this thing here okay I
don't know if Joe would we call him
Obama would probably be calling and
saying hey what are you doing to fix
this thing here anyways I think I think
if there's ever been an opportunity for
California to really stand up because
this is a message only to those that
don't want to leave the state of
California they do not want to leave the
state of California you don't want to
leave the state of California well let's
show up
let's show up because your alternative
is to say I'm leaving I'm out so either
an exodus or guess what a you fight you
fight you gotta fight but if you stay in
the middle the disguiser you were you
know like the other day somebody said
why would you ever bring Anthony Weiner
to the podcast
why would you ever do that I got so many
calls about Anthony Weiner so funny one
day Anthony Weiner I love the way Pat
fought next day Chris Coma hey you know
Chris coming let's listen Anthony Weiner
comes in and I said guys you have to
realize if this guy if you get into a
wrestling match with a you know you mud
wrestle with a pig
and they love it and guess what I have
no problem yep I'm not going to be the
proper scared person to say well you
know for me with my three-piece suit I'm
gonna sit outside because there's no way
you're gonna see me wrestling but no no
sometimes you gotta wrestle with the pig
yep and you got to get dirty this whole
thing about us being too proper to want
to wrestle with a pig you got to get in
there and Bully him around a little bit
for him to realize and say [__] I'm not
you know at the end he starts
apologizing nobody asks you to apologize
he starts apologizing and then on
Twitter he says well he asked me four
times to apologize not one time that I
ever asked this guy to apologize because
he wrestling with a damn pig that's how
they are you gotta fight you gotta show
up so for me they're already doing it
the only thing these parents are missing
in California is only one thing
for all of them to get on one Zoom
together
and say guys let's unite and let's roll
okay if they can do that they will scare
the crap out of the governor and all the
other people that are bullying these
great parents that all they're trying to
do is raise good kids yep and if that
falls into remember the three things the
three people that you're talking about
the do nothing the what the lazy but the
other Republic it's this isn't a left
right this is for your kids y'all got
you guys have to step up and you got to
do something about you imagine if I was
in those zooms I get it the passion is
there it's like they need a little spark
and set the [__] there's a question
during the Revolutionary War I can't
remember who said it now which really
pisses me off I don't remember that but
if we don't hang together we will
certainly hang separately yeah and they
were talking about going up against the
British by the way what is that's the
way this goes do you want to be hung out
on your kid if you don't hang together
you're all going to be stuck you're
right Benjamin Franklin we must indeed
all hang together uh uh most assuredly
we shall all hang separately wow that's
you're right that's dope by the way you
know what is crazy you know what is
crazy there was a guy I worked with uh
20 years ago guy's name was Swan okay
the guy is known as the best in his
industry and what he does a lot of
respect for this man
he would say unify simplify multiply
okay so Californians must first unify
then they must simplify a message in all
the different districts then they must
multiply unify simplify multiply unify
simplify multiply if they do that the
whole reason why the greatest team in
the last decade
is a team called Golden State Warriors
to have a very famous saying strength in
numbers strength in numbers you unify
you will scare the crap out of them I'll
never forget I was recruiting guys to
come to PHP Insurance sell insurance
and it was the best to hear what the
competitor was saying about us okay and
there was a seal of this company big
company massive company he would say
look you can go anywhere we will not Sue
you there's only one company you go to
we will sue you
and they would say I don't know why they
keep telling me but what they don't
realize is they were saying this to 50
other people and they were all calling
me first wow so like you just can't go
with Pat you can go anywhere you can't
go with pan you go anywhere we will not
do anything to you but if we find out
you go with Pat we're suing you what
were their fearing strengthen numbers
they knew if these guys were more
divided it's easier to compete when
people are divided because this this
game is a very very hard game they don't
want to see different people unify with
each other just think about the state of
government California they don't want to
see different districts unified with
each other they want to see all the
bickering fighting we're better you're
better our Instagram has more followers
than yours our videos go more viral than
yours and you copied us and that's our
hashtag and don't use our hashtag no
they want to be able to say can we agree
that we all have a common enemy yes
who's the common enemy the governor at
the top that's ruining these things for
us yes great why don't we unify
simplify multiply against a common enemy
which is who
the governor they divide and conquer you
got to do what you said did you see the
video CNN made yesterday can you pull up
my Twitter profile you didn't see the
video cnma yesterday trying to trash the
santis not as if it's a bad thing you're
going to watch this video thinking these
guys are trying to refresh the
scientists what's the context you have
to see this video it's comical and I
said this is this is probably the best
right there that one right there the
second one this is probably the best at
this is a better ad than any AD the
sentences Camp has done CNN has done a
better cap Camp a marketing ad for Ronda
santis watch this just play the first 30
first minute watch this clip here
they're trying to trash it a second we
just thought it would be a nice warm
place to live where we could get to
beaches
I just never thought that I would have
to flee a state for the boxes my
children the SB 254 uh this will
permanent Outlaw the mutilation of
minors great yeah good job makes sense
this isn't a sketch Pat this is real
this is mandatory coming to me one time
and in tears which she doesn't normally
do I asked her what was wrong and she
said to Santas and like the fact that a
governor would be making my kid cry
that's a messed up government
we're absolutely moving because there's
a great state
in Florida we didn't want to move
when the Florida Board of Medicine
started meeting and we realized that
they were going to ban gender affirming
care for kids that we might need to
leave because that is life-saving
essential medicine and treatment for our
daughter oh I was very impressed by the
way do you do does it actually look like
it's a complex I swear I'm waiting for
the punch guys I'm not joking by the way
I thought this is a comedy sketch this
goes like this the entire time and the
girl said that the boy says I can't take
puberty blockers I I can't take it in
this state I can't live here we gotta
leave so by the way I'm waiting for and
we'd like to thank the inventor by the
way the dick saw by the way this is the
best time this is the best time for
parents in California to unite yeah you
could lead a movement in the entire
country I have a feeling if they unite
and actually bring some pain to the
state State other states are going to
have to cave this is how it works other
states will cave and say damn we better
do something about this you think
somebody you think they will though Pat
like where people like you having the
the not telling people like it's your
kids this isn't like dude listen don't
mess with Armenians Armenians are very
weird Community you saw the statista
report that shows the top 10 angriest
countries Armenians are number three
number one is Lebanon number two is
turkey number three is Armenian I mean
they play games but but you know who
else won't conservative Hispanics yeah
like Hispanics like Ricky you know who
else won't play conservative
African-Americans they won't play the
conservative African-Americans don't
agree with what's going on here right
now they just don't publicly talk about
it because they're Democrats there's a
lot of people that this is not just
Armenians this is Hispanics this is
African Americans this is good Christian
valued white Americans that want to do
there are a lot of people that are
sitting there saying this is nonsense
one of the good one of the families that
send me videos this is the challenge
though they send a video and they send
it to my sister
and they send it to Mario they said we
want you to come and we we would love to
have you here but the only thing we have
for you is we don't want to be any other
agenda but just to talk about this I
mean this is not your show there's there
is an agenda you know what the agenda is
here's the agenda vote accordingly yeah
okay the agenda is start really studying
What policies are causing this because
you're living in California you've been
voting the same exact way you're not
happy with what's going on but you're
saying there shouldn't be any agenda
there should be an agenda the agenda is
vote accordingly bad policies ruin great
States
you lost the goat of business the last
30 years Elon Musk left you lost a goat
of podcasts in the last 20 years Joe
Rogan left you're losing people that are
liberals Rogan's not a republican musk
is not a republican they left the state
they love because the policies no longer
matter Mark Wahlberg Hollywood left
so I think I think there's a big
opportunity I didn't say it's going to
be easy and and the same thing with Iran
you know we're sitting on we're like
well you need to go out there and do
this you need to go out there and do
that you need to go out there and do
something you're not in Iran the fear of
doing anything with your kids the only
difference here is
the harm the harming of your kids okay
they can't do anything this is not Iran
there are laws we have social media
people are seeing this document the hell
out of it have a camera everywhere
citizen journalism everywhere let people
show what antifa's all about I saw a
girl that said something I thought it
was great she says I'm not worried about
antifa I faced against an antifa member
they were scared of us we don't need no
Mongols and these guys
now Christian you know change their
lives people who show up these antifa
people are not tough people they're weak
she's right but they've scared the crap
out of you to the point where in Alex
theater in a Hilton in Glendale is not
willing to do it and unfortunately those
are two of the biggest places you can do
those events anyways do you remember
when we had Nikki freed on the podcast I
sure do she was running for governor she
lost to Charlie Chris she was running
against Rhonda Sanders essentially yeah
yeah and you remember the argument that
she made I'm like so tell me why
you're gonna beat Ron DeSantis like
what's your message if you were gonna be
his opponent she eventually lost to
Charlie Chris who got what lampooned by
DeSantis by 20 points yeah and she's
like you have no idea
and by the way respect to her for coming
on the podcast respect respect so we're
not I'm not like trying her but her
argument made no sense she's like you
have no idea how many people I talked to
that want to leave this state and
they're fleeing the state because of Ron
desantises cruel inhumane anti-woke
agenda I'm like yeah no you don't yeah
no you know like what I told her to do
yeah remember what I told her to do I
said who
you know whether he wins for president
or not that's another conversation but
he Landslide here in Florida and that
this we're speaking of the CNN
commercial it's like how uh minute of an
audience is a transgender teen parent
considering leaving the state because of
dissonian uh desantis's Draconian law
it's like you're it's insane you're
coming down to the lowest common
denominator that nobody cares I thought
there was a set designer that put empty
boxes in the dude that look that by the
way and Joey just message me I'm doing a
sketch making fun of that that is
brilliant comedy let's lay on let's move
yeah let's go I give these parents a d
for the following reasons obviously that
young person has got some emotional
things when you say these parents let's
qualify the CNN parents the CNN parents
here Epiphany and Kelly McKee wait
Tiffany and Kelly they're both hang on
hang on I don't get it they're both
gonna move on but I'm making a point
here I give these people a d for two
reasons number one it's obviously that
that young person their son now
identifies as female it says it's got
something going on and needs counseling
and there are great counselors out there
to figure out what's going on are you
just gay what what's going on here and
the second thing is these parents are
not doing that so they're not supporting
the true need of the child number one
and number two they're teaching him now
her to run and they're not sitting down
to face these things of life and I give
them a d for that it's not about trans
that I'm saying it's not about anything
what I'm saying is these parents are
getting a D in my book you teach them to
run and now you'll be in New York you
won't like that where do you run next
his father's name is Kelly his father
Run next when I saw the father run run
the moment I saw the father's name is
Kelly I was like okay it's a wrap it's
over wait a minute by the way well
played on giving them the D I get it
yeah acquitted on all nine sexual
offense charges in London trial this is
a Reuters story Kevin Spacey is
acquitted from all nine with the jury
finding him not guilty by majority after
12 hours and 26 minutes of deliberation
during the trial space emotionally
thanked the jurors and stated I'm
humbled by the outcome today and
expressed gratitude for the to the for
the jury's careful examination of the
evidence of the evidence Spacey face
accusations of being a sexual bully and
aggressively groping three men while he
claimed the incident if they occurred
were consensual describing himself as
promiscuous and engaging in casual
indiscriminate sexual encounters the
accusations led to significant
professional consequences for the actor
in 2017 with his removal from TV drama
House of Cards and a movie all the money
in the world Vinnie what do you thought
well first of all acting wise you
already know Kevin Spacey usual uh
suspect House of Cards one of my
favorite shows ever and still still is
he was found guilty right that his
lawyer said his name is Patrick Gibbs he
told the jury verbatim and I quote it
was not a crime for his client to enjoy
casual gay sex because it's 2023 not 18
23 and the four four victims of this
said that he was vile he was a sexual
predator slippery which I never heard
anybody call somebody slippery which is
weird atrocious despicable and
disgusting and let's not forget
everybody uh in 2019 back in the day
three of his past accusers died Ari Ben
committed suicide Linda Culkin hit by a
car and another John Doe which the cause
of death was unknown and then mind you
he was accused for groping Anthony Rapp
who was 14 years old at the time uh
Elton John Pat you know how good it like
this was in London it helps when Elton
John comes to your side and speaks as a
witness to the jury I'm pretty sure that
didn't help anything but dude what's
scary is and I know people forgot back
when one of these guys committed suicide
one of his accusers
Kevin Spacey made a video during
Christmas that to me basy said to people
because he says you kill them with
kindness he says dead and killed him
with kindness twice Rob can you show
this video so people can see how scary
and creepy this freaking guy is
We Wish You a Merry Christmas did you
it's been a pretty good year music and
I'm grateful to have my health back and
in light of that I've made some changes
in my life and I'd like to invite you to
join me this is not a movie no no it's
not a movie and his accuser just died
committed suicide hash my vote for
it's not that hard trust me watch the
next time someone does something you
don't like
you can go on the attack but you can
also hold your fire and do the
unexpected
you can
kill them with kindness are you are you
kidding me
Patrick by the way that's just a skit
yeah
that's a video that's a real that's not
a skit by the way
just to be clear let me say one thing
MasterCards he's speaking in a Southern
accent he's doing he's playing a
character here
he's doing Frank from enough okay okay
so there you go guys guys time out I've
he's doing it he paid for this
production he's basically saying
somebody just died that said that he
groped or gave them a [__] and he
made this video saying you kill them
with kindness if that's not him saying
if you f with me you're going to die and
he's smirking and he's laughing that's
the Hollywood Elite Untouchable I said
it two weeks ago he knows he's gonna
walk scot-free and that's this is the
protected Elite Epstein perverted
messing with 14 year olds that we
[__] just saying yeah it's all good
it's all good just like what's his name
Pat who is the actor uh the one with the
hoods with his wife was crying about the
kid that he molested Uh Wood Woody Allen
Woody Allen we let this [__] go and he's
gonna walk scot-free and that's it bro
that's scary and that's disgusting about
groping 14 year old kids he also grow
what's his name uh who's the other actor
um the one that was uh there's a couple
things when you look at this here so
there's a couple things okay I I
subscribe to innocent till proven guilty
that's number one I do uh because for
for for us to go hardcore after him and
then when people say what about Tate
what about Tate what about tayden it's
like no this guy's for sure guilty but
no those guys are innocent I subscribe
to innocent until proven guilty period
now having said that do I think O.J
Simpson is innocent no I don't and
neither does anybody else in America if
you go right now pull up the poll what
percentage of Americans think O.J
Simpson killed uh uh you know Nicole
Brown and see what the percentage is and
you'll see what numbers come up uh a
recent poll on what percentage 71
percent think so okay and it keeps
increasing year after year after year
and today's even higher than that by the
way if you show the poll right the Civil
Trial he was found guilty right from the
goldense and Pat even his yeah but he
didn't do time he didn't go away no into
anything he was free there was an
emotional day when the announcement was
made riots were outside OJ's out right
and he'd go to Michael Jackson you know
I mean what's wrong with them having
underwears everywhere this is just very
friendly when they sleep in my bed I'm
like no bro there's nothing normal about
that and guess what nothing really
happened there with Michael Jackson okay
Michael didn't go to jail Michael didn't
do anything of course you know God Rest
the soul you know whether he's in heaven
or hell that's not on us that's on God
to decide that but the point is
this isn't the first time a powerful
Hollywood celebrity got away with
literally murder that can be said okay
100 yeah that can be said so that's the
part that you can defend for me if if
you were to ask somebody do you think he
did those things and we run a poll I
think probably most people are going to
say I believe he did how he got away
with it in London I don't know how the
courts are in London I don't know if
they're stricter I don't know if they're
more lenient I don't know if they're
anything else I don't even know if that
case can be opened in a different
country or in a different you know I
don't know any of that stuff I don't
know what's going to happen there but
yeah but when he had 14 year old a 14
year old actor said he wrote me and
tried to rape me at what point do we say
okay enough is enough and the arrogance
to make that video is just like when OJ
you brought up OJ great point he wrote a
book called and didn't get published I
didn't do it but if I did this is how I
would have killed her yeah what the [__]
I'm sorry Pat what the OJ thing what
let's not complete OJ who no it doesn't
matter literally killed somebody no two
people no but it's weird whatever Kevin
Space video I'm gonna ask you a question
you asked me too
yeah do you think he's guilty or do you
want Kevin Spacey to be guilty think
about it like I'll tell you you want him
to be good definitely not I told him I
told you I'm a huge fan of his work I've
been following him for all these years I
think he is because why would two 14
year olds kid Richard dreyfus's son was
another one like what are these kids we
don't believe kids no he's he looks by
the way and because people were like my
friend was like he's gay they're not
it's not even who gives a damn he's he
one of these accusers that was in London
said that while he was sleeping he took
off his pants I don't know how the guy
didn't wake up but he was trying to give
him a [__] when the guy was sleeping
and it's like bro it's sexual assault
and the line that I draw Pat and you
know this when it's to the kids when
it's a 14 year old kid and what your
lawyer's better than that kid and that's
what you get off no no no bro no no no
no I'm sorry listen I mean they're off
limits but by the way if you watch the
Michael Jackson interviews
there's plenty of interviews when you're
watching you're like dude that that's
sick what you just said right now yeah
we're just we're just just purchasing
bad we're not doing anything it's just
innocent you know it's just kids it's
this it's dead like no and then and then
the the the what do you call it the mate
is like no there was always underwears
there with stains in the underwear in
the interview of the documentary and all
of some people coming out saying I can't
believe you said this and they forced
this guy to flip the script look there's
a lot of dark stuff that happens in
Hollywood that's for sure the story is
endless I mean you got a story here with
a guy that just comes out from Epstein
okay watch this billionaire Leon black
paid Jeffrey Epstein 158 million dollars
over five years what for what for now
watch when the story continues and how
all of a sudden it flips and becomes a
very very weird story here with Epstein
what this guy did
yeah so so 150 million dollars Leon
black 158 million dollars from 2012 to
2017 with the Senate finance committee
now scrutinizing the extraordinary
transactions black claimed the payments
were for advice on trust and estate
planning tax issues and his family's
office operations
158 million dollars in fees for state
I'm going through estate planning right
now it's a lot of money it ain't 158
million dollars now Senator Ron Wyden
raised concerns about the payments which
appear to exceed those to professional
advisors and question why black sought
advice from Epstein black resigned from
his Apollo uh firm Apollo in 2021 after
the law firm investigation revealed
Epstein's involvement in advising him on
tax avoidance and selling portions of
his one billion dollar art collection
black is currently facing a federal
lawsuit from an unnamed woman who
alleges he raped her when she was 16
years old at Epstein's home with blacks
attorney dismissing to lawsuit as
uncorroborated now Rob pull up the next
story and and just actually put it up
the New York Post story and and look at
this here guys look at this here New
York Post and what's the date July 25th
billionaire uh uh oh Leon black accused
of raping autistic teen after handoff
from Epstein lawsuit what okay so so let
me let me read this here uh a
billionaire investor faces allegations
of raping an autistic teenager at
Jeffrey ever since Manhattan match in
2002 after Epstein arranged the
encounter the victim referred to as Jane
Doe accuses black a violently assaulting
her with sex toys causing her to bleed
while she was only 16 years old
according to the lawsuit the victim was
trafficked by Epstein and jelaine
Maxwell for about a year before the
incident with black making her
vulnerable Target due to her Mosaic Down
syndrome condition
Epstein supposedly introduced her to
Black saying he was important and a
special friend Black's lawyer Susan
Estridge denies the claim stating he
never met this woman he doesn't know her
at all we're confident the lawsuit is
totally uncorroborated by any evidence
so why did you pay 158 million dollars
in five years for for advice for advice
158 million dollars wow story stories
like this are coming out and and the
biggest question is going to be the
following for the longest time what's
one of the best what's one in the movie
give me movie titles about the mops you
know what was one of the titles yeah but
what's one of the ones untouched
Untouchable Untouchables why did they
name it Untouchables because uh
Untouchable yeah the the mob in Chicago
yeah you're untouchable there's no way
this is going to happen yeah and then
all of a sudden
a guy undercover FBI agent for five
years and 10 months Joe pastone AKA
Donnie which I was one of the first to
interview him and that thing got like 10
million views right when we did the
interview and we did the interview in
Boca I think eight years ago seven years
seven eight years ago
for eight years for five years and ten
months he acted like he was part of the
family helping him out at the parties
everything he was doing everything and
all of a sudden one day he got so deep
into it
that the FBI finally said you ain't
doing this anymore he was about to get
killed
he comes out how many people get caught
240 something people get caught and what
happens to the Mob The Untouchables over
with overnight and all you saw was 240
men arrested dressed nice suits walking
out arrested and it was unbelievable how
they finally got him how did they
finally get uh Al Capone it was based on
what taxes right okay so right now if we
were to say the modern day Untouchables
who are the modern data Untouchables you
can put Epstein Maxwell Jordan Hunter
Hunter
you can you can put Clinton's part of
The Untouchables the best you can put uh
quite a lot of people that are part of
the Untouchables Community okay fauci
he's part of the Untouchable community
and and there's this notion like if you
were living in New York uh I'll never
forget I went to the restaurant with
mayor Giuliani Italian restaurant you
guys been there before and the owner
shows up okay and he sees the mayor
and he's Italian the owner is Italian in
his 60s it's time we love this guy and
he says hey uh mayor Giuliani I just
have to tell you I just want to thank
you for what you did to cleaning the
streets of New York it was so unsafe we
were so worried that thank you for
making it safer and he's thanking him
he's emotional a 60-something-year-old
Italian man is emotional because they
never thought the streets of New York
were going to get cleaned up okay that's
the impression I got from the way he was
talking to Mayor Giuliani I've never
lived in New York but I've interviewed
almost every single living mob person
the top most powerful mob people that
have been interviewed I've talked to all
of them can I got a relationship with
all of them on what happened to because
I want to learn from myself
so there's this notion that people like
you
Vinnie who they want you to eventually
believe nothing's ever going to happen
to these guys they want you to believe
that they want you to go there and they
want you to convince other people that
nothing's ever going to happen because
they see themselves as what The
Untouchables but let me tell you
something man the world Works in a very
weird way okay uh uh when when I was
when I've been in this business for some
times and I've seen certain things
people do behind closers and I say this
is not a good idea
this is just not a good idea what you're
doing it's not going to work eventually
one person came out two people three
people four people five people six
people seven I was like that's not going
to be working out
we're starting to see all these stories
an average person is going to sit there
who has hired a lawyer before who's
hired an accountant before and more
importantly Tom how many billionaires
are reading this article there's 700
billionaires in America 700 to 900
billionaires in America
the average billionaire who's reading
this not the average billionaire any
billionaire that's reading this you know
what they're saying
they're sitting there saying man in my
life I haven't spent 158 million dollars
in Vice fees fees and fees we sold the
company and we spent a lot of money to
sell a company you ain't spending 158
million dollars you do estate planning
with the best that does all the family
planning for billionaires you don't
spend that kind of money doing Estate
Planning and it's a complex estate
planning
I guarantee every single billionaire
knows this guy's a dark guy to stay away
from if you paid I've seen 150 billion
dollars the only people that will still
befriend this guy are also people that
give Epstein money behind closed doors
and it was also they want to be able to
see yeah this is very normal I did too
this is very normal I did two there's
anybody that says this is very normal
probably also paid Epstein some money
probably so and you know it's a it's
like a struggle especially because you
know I've changed in the past six months
I'm going to church I'm trying to be you
know a better person on Sunday you know
the the pastor was like instead of
people thinking you have to LEAP into
this loving God and you just take these
little steps to become better and in my
head Pat it's the attitude of since
humans don't look like they're doing it
God at one point is going to deal with
these people but the other thing that we
heard pan you know because you were
there it's you have to love your enemies
which is one of the hardest things that
I've been struggling with is like all
these evil demons that are out we're
told that we're supposed to still love
them you're supposed to have compassion
question for these people and that's the
most difficult thing I'm dealing with
because I hope I'm I'm having whole path
from what you're saying is people are
waking up and the laws and everything is
changing they're going to be held
accountable here but I personally don't
see it happening here and the only
comfort that I was getting is that God
God will make these people forget what
God uses though guess who God uses
Hafiz wrote a poem years ago can you
type in Hafiz flute
put hafez flute God I'd love to read
this quote to you please uh okay they're
right there right there okay okay right
to click on that zoom in
he says I am a hole in the flute that
the Christ's breath moves through listen
to this music
okay listen to this music I'm the
concert from the mouth of every creature
singing with the my rate chorus quote
from Hafiz now somebody may say I'm a
hole in the flute that the Christ priest
breath moves through listen to this
music do you know why I never miss
church on Sundays because my fear was
that was the Sunday that God was going
to speak to me through somebody else
using that person as a flute I didn't
want to miss service wow do you know why
I never miss sales training I never miss
sales training because in my mind I was
afraid that that week when I was asking
for questions from God I was worried God
was trying to deliver a message to me I
was going to miss that message you know
sometimes people run out of a meeting
and they skip and like I don't need to
behind on it's a mistake because God
uses people to talk to you God uses
people to give an answer to a question
of yours that you're having I also
believe God's a tool uh for fighting the
evil is other people you know there was
a story
about a marine that's sitting in a
classroom and a guy says
I guarantee you if the god really exists
watches if God really exists let's see
if anything will happen to me I can
prove to you right now that God does not
exist a marine walk down and punch the
guy in the face wow so what's the matter
with you so I just want to prove to you
that God exists wow he told me to come
and punch you in the face thank you God
exist you can't talk like that about god
wow whether that's a true story yeah
what's a metaphor that's not okay but
the point is this about evil and I'll
come to you I don't think that my
interpretation with the whole tolerance
thing I don't think he's saying love
your enemies as in like let's go love
the behavior of jalaine Maxwell and
Epstein and some of these other guys
I don't think that's what he's saying
because
you know God's enemy was who the devil
evil you know Lucifer this guy fell and
he wanted to go and convert everybody
into his way of thinking and half his
battle was convincing you know the best
line in the movie Fallen as what the
greatest trick the devil ever played it
was convincing man he didn't existence
this convincing the man that he you know
she was like oh my God I was uh Usual
Suspects there was also that was also
both movies yeah okay so so so it's so
funny we're talking about usual
suspecting the devil so this doesn't
mean we sit there and we say it's okay
what Kevin did this doesn't mean we sit
there and we said it's okay with Jelena
these guys are doing that that's not
that that's not what that means and
that's not what I was saying but I'm
just saying I love them because they're
impure people you still got you still
got a love on it I know you still got a
love on him it's not easy to do go ahead
Tom well I think Richard you're bringing
up here is is very clear and there's a
very very simple Maxim that is at the
core of um the love your enemies tenant
that Christ taught and he basically says
hate sin but love The Sinner love your
enemy because inside that person who is
committing sin is a human is just as
flawed as you that needs love and needs
my salvation and he says your sin will
find you out and there will be
consequences that's very simple there it
is right there you love your enemies but
don't put yourself in a position to be
hurt by them but inside that person
should they be able to leave the life of
sin behind and set aside the sin and
uncover there is a core person in there
that is just as valuable as you are and
that's it's so simple but it doesn't
mean love them and put yourself in Peril
it just means you know your enemies
without the sin is a person like you and
by the way I love I love the direction
you're going do we want to go hunter
bite or Mitch McConnell next I have some
quick numbers for you real quick about
uh Leon black this is so what I'd like
to do right now is just this isn't in my
opinion let's you know follow the money
we're talking about Leon black here with
Epstein and all that so his firm is
Apollo Global well I mean massive
Financial firm hedge fund whatever you
want to call them they're massive right
um his net worth as of today I guess is
10 billion dollars okay so would you go
with me here
in 2012
to 2017 do you think his net worth was
less or more back then
I would say less probably less of course
right because you you just I'll be
making money well okay so here's the
deal right money's gonna go up so we're
talking maybe 10 years ago maybe his net
worth was 5 billion right is that fair
yeah okay maybe it's seven okay so
um in the asset management game in the
AUM game Pat what is like we're not
giving you a sweetheart deal we're not
hooking you up we're not giving you a
discount we're gonna give you the normal
rate you got you have a million bucks
you have 10 million bucks we're gonna
charge you what percent
one percent one is that fair yep okay so
let's say
all right you want to bring over 10
billion dollars or 5 billion dollars
are we going to reduce our one percent
fee yes yes maybe you reduce it to what
half a percent half a percent yeah okay
because the number of dollars is so high
it takes care of all the services you're
providing I mean it's like if you're
gonna sell a real like a home for 20
million dollar home and it's like yeah I
know usually take six percent you're
gonna do this thing for three percent
yeah you gotta we're gonna do six
percent on the first million we're gonna
do three percent keep going to make the
point so here's the point bat you're a
math guy allegedly this guy paid 158
million bucks 2012 2017. if you're worth
10 billion dollars
what's one percent of 10 billion dollars
10 million no 100 million 100 million
100 million dollars so best case
scenario we're going to charge this guy
the full amount he's worth 10 billion
dollars like follow the money here at
the very [__] most yeah you're
talking a hundred million dollars but he
somehow paid 158 million now
you said a half a percent which I think
is I think you would do even a quarter
percent but let's even use a half a
percent your 100 million just went down
to 50 million dollars I think that's
fair what's my point
how the hell are you paying 158 million
dollars for advice something's up yeah
of course on 10 billion dollars maybe
you're paying and this is just assets
under management whatever straight fee
based only whatever
maybe it's 25 50 million
we said that a long time ago yeah it
just doesn't make sense for you to do
that on 10 billion you're right one
percent is 100 million dollars no listen
it takes a naive oblivious person to say
there's nothing Shady going on here for
this guy to pay you know what this
conversation looked like what are the
chances the conversation was like this
hey Leon
uh I gotta have a meeting with you you
want to come to my office I'm busy trust
me you're not busy enough make the time
the other party yep so you come to the
meeting
um okay I want you to watch this real
quick uh watch what dude just watch this
on my phone
oh [__] yeah so I have the video okay
just so you know what happened that day
so here's what I need you to do yeah I
need you to pay me
150 million dollars over the next three
or five years
uh for me not to present this to anybody
else I won't tell anybody I won't give
it to court I won't do anything your
family won't know nobody will know yeah
but if you do that with me I'll protect
you I'll do this I'll do that I'll do
this and you can call this fees as a
consulting fee so that's what I need for
I need you to sell a portion of your art
collection to pay up for this I can't
believe you're doing this totally
understand Leon that's my business it's
just business nothing personal it's just
business nothing personal wow and then
he goes away huffing and puffing and
angry and all this stuff but he paid 150
million dollars yeah and here's what the
script's going to be when you tell the
public you're a billionaire somebody
worth your money no one's going to care
if you paid me 158 million dollars when
you were 10 billion and it's not going
to hurt you so I expect that money in my
account by such and such years the
routing number here is this WOW Mary
will call you to get that money set up
okay what's the likelihood that
conversation took place what you just
here's the video now by the way might
may be wrong but I think it went
something something like that a little
something like that let's go with uh you
want to go 100 Mitch McConnell let's
talk about Hunter both okay let's go
with Hunter first so video 100 Brighton
please net pleads not guilty to tax
charges and Delaware Federal Court this
is a Wall Street Journal story Rob if
you can pull up the video and uh uh let
me see do we actually have a story here
or is it just a clip that you have
to show because I think oh there it is
it's the page 600 right and I'm going to
read the what the judge said about it
okay judge refuses to accept Hunter
Brighton's plea deal after initial
grooming falls apart in court this is an
Insider story uh Hunter Biden's attempt
guilty plea to two tax crime charges
fails as the judge raises concerns about
the agreement scope and potential
immunity from future prosecutions uh
related to business dealings the plea
agreement was null and void after
questions arose in Delaware Federal
Court prosecutors accused Biden of
illegally avoiding taxes in 2017 and 18
with them reportedly owing around 1.2
million dollars which he later Paid in
Full the revised plea agreement covers
2014-2019 focusing on tax offenses drug
uses and gun possession the U.S District
Judge Marilyn Noriega and appointee of
former president Donald Trump declined
to accept a plea deal and express
concerns about the scope of the charges
leaving The Plea on hold as the case
unfolds so uh Tom are you following the
story closely or no uh as as close as
close as I want to Vinnie what do you
have on well Rob Rob has a video pack
and that I'll show after this but what
you guys don't realize is what happened
yesterday one of Hunter Biden's uh
lawyers contacted the court clerk's
office falsely claiming to be part of
the house Ways and Means legal team and
asked the clerk to pull the adverse
filings of 10 technical reasons so they
were doing like some trickery and they
got caught the court figured out what
happened and demanded answers from
hunting it's pretty wild dude Pat that
you should be this bored as a lawyer
you're calling pretending to be somebody
else anyway they got caught uh and I
think they should be this boy but Pat
here's a question that I I saw this live
this is Hunter Biden uh a private
citizen I don't give a [__] who Sonny is
he's showing up to the courthouse and a
six-car secret service Convoy detail
with other like 20 other Secret Service
Pat show this and then tell me who's
paying for this look at this this is not
the president this is the president's
son look at this protection bro
and look how you see all the Secret
Service on the right yeah of course
that's that's the lead the lead vehicle
has to stop they have to go there for
for just in case somebody wants to do
something crazy they give the okay you
would think the president of the United
States is coming out of the vehicle
right you guys are all paying for this
look at this and you talked about Mr
Untouchable that's him right there
Untouchable going into court and
nothing's gonna happen to him well his
lawyers are calling the clerk Adam
that's all dude you know how illegal
that is what they just did and nothing's
gonna happen but but here's the part
about why what if you're a conservative
and you hate Donald Trump because you're
a rhino or you're the Santa sky or
whatever you are
if there's anything you have to know
that why this screws it up for Hunter
and people like that out of all the
states that you could have chosen to
appoint
a U.S District Judge Trump appoints
Judge Marilyn Noriega in Delaware out of
all the states you don't think he knew
eventually something could happen that
this judge is going to come back and
help him out I don't know I think I
think these are the types of things that
you realize the if there's anything we
learned in 2016 the election he flipped
three seeds that's what led to Roe v
Wade that's what led to a lot of these
other tax things that they couldn't do
that's what led to them wanting to make
the election all based on what he called
it um uh who gets the most votes rather
than electorality they want to do the
popular vote that's what they wanted to
change if they had it they would have
changed that they would have changed so
many different things and these judges
so you know love it or hate the guy the
guy appointed some judges that are now
backfiring on the people to say Hey you
thought you were going to get full-on
Immunity on additional thing that's
going on uh-uh that's not going to fly
with us we can eventually actually see
what's going on here by the way for
another person similar to the offense
that Hunter Biden has that person went
to jail for five years under this judge
same exact just same exact same exact
crime five years yes go ahead all right
by the way
um fully appreciate what you're saying
about the judges we talked about that in
2020 when when during the election and
everything with that
um
here's the way I see this I mean we can
have the whole Hunter Biden discussion
you know he should have registered with
the barisma as registered as a foreign
agent and the foreign agent uh
Resolution Act and he got paid 8 million
bucks and barisma and all that nonsense
um he's facing what he's facing I think
that the maximum sentence right here by
the way the best medication is going on
five years five years maximum sentence
is 12 months in prison apparently and 25
000 for each account it's according to
the Wall Street Journal
um
I would argue the macro perspective here
okay because ultimately if Joe Biden
loses the election nobody's gonna ever
say the name Hunter Biden again who
gives a [__] nobody will it's over like
the whole thing is
comes down to
at this point the economy is doing
better we address that unemployment's
down inflation's doing okay we'll see
where the stock market is in terms of
election
I would argue that Hunter Biden is Joe
Biden's number one political liability
at this point I agree he's a [__]
liability okay you think so you know
they everyone made the the joke that Joe
Biden was uh hiding in the basement
during 2020 I wouldn't be surprised if
Hunter Biden goes on a little vacation
uh come election season and everything
will be whether it's dismissed whether
there's a um whether they there's a plea
deal whatever
he's wanted to do everything he can to
get this over and done with by the time
2024 starts and that's a political
liability Kamala Harris is his vice
president
exactly but but but at the end of the
day Adam and I I get what you're saying
it's the accountability of and it's not
dude I can give two shits about Hunter
he's the luckiest dumbest crackhead on
the planet it's all the stuff that those
laptops have about him the big guy the
text his father is implicated with
everything with Russia with Ukraine
everything and guess what we're sending
all this money to Ukraine because it's
almost like they have all this dirt on
him and they're like listen keep the
billions coming or like Pat said with
the video with that ogre billionaire
we're going to expose all the [__] that
you did so zelinski's like keep the
money coming keep the flags going and
I'm not there why wouldn't you be like
the whole Ukraine war is not the whole
world at the end of the day it's a NATO
situation 100 macroeconomic Russia take
that's a whole conversation then eight
million dollars no not eight eight
million dollars no what I'm saying is
the president is compromised if the
president's compromised through all this
information on the laptop it's not just
Barista it's China China it's oh it's
all this stuff Adam it's his son's
dumbass exposed the father but again
we're going with the Untouchables you
can't touch these people bro they're in
and when you have the FBI and the doj in
your back pocket you're good bro you can
get away with literally murder the whole
procedural side here is what really
stinks I mean yesterday yesterday I was
reading this is the part I dug into that
I really didn't want to but it caught my
eye and I dug into it while his lawyers
his Hunter his lawyers are in there and
trying to put together this plea deal
and the judge is asking the prosecutors
have you completed all of your
investigations and they said no and she
asked have you completed the Foreign
Corrupt individuals investigation
they're like no we haven't and then
she's saying well then how can we agree
to a plea deal on this charge with the
gun and on this charge here how can you
agree to a plea deal if there's still
investigation ongoing and not all of the
charges are here that you're going to
play out on you have to complete the
investigation to say the investigation
is completed and there's these five
charges okay bottom two cancel the
middle one top two you gotta take guilty
and then we'll give you the and we'll do
the fine and we'll do the sentencing
like here are you guys in agreement
that's how plea deals work in judges
Chambers but yeah so let me let me show
this on what he's saying okay
he be in Vinnie Rob I'm going to send
this to you I want you to uh pull this
up if you can or Google
Ukraine BlackRock hundreds of billions
okay Ukraine BlackRock hundreds of
billions was this the rebuild plan yeah
so if you look at this this just came
out with financial times if you can
click on that okay I don't know if it's
going to let you okay good zoom in a
little bit so BlackRock and JPMorgan
help set up Ukraine reconstruction Bank
okay fund aimed to attract billions of
dollars in private Investments but it's
not billions of dollars if you go lower
this is another story that was done
there it is right there Black Rock Gym
memory Ukraine Governor is
reconstruction Bank to steer public seed
Capital into rebuilding projects that
can attract ready hundreds of billions
of dollars in private Investments so
what is this I interviewed who's the
guy's name that we had on multiple times
the economic Hitman uh Perkins what's
his first time John Perkins yeah we have
John Perkins and John's job was to be an
economic Hitman he would go to countries
who had a lot of resources and he would
say hey here's what we're gonna do we're
going to come and build up a bunch of
different things here for you but this
is what we're going to ask from you you
have to listen to everything we do we'll
bring jobs we'll do this we'll do that
we'll do this we'll do that if you don't
we'll kill you that was his job by the
way if you've never read his book or
what he this guy's a Democrat full-blown
liberal on the other side
and he wrote this book it was a big hit
this book I think yeah confessions of an
economic Hitman yeah that's what he did
for a living He told me to my face you
know what he said he says you know what
would happen to a guy like you if you
run a good country he said what I said
you wouldn't be alive for too long a guy
like you because you wouldn't agree to
what we're doing so guess what publicly
we are seeing the consequences of an
economic Hitman taking advantage of
Ukraine that if you go type in Ukraine
resources they have some of the best
resources in the world that we need it's
not like it's a place without any
resources Ukraine resources on where
they rank type in Ukraine resources
ranking like medals everything right
everything is in that ground brother
they are one of the best the country
ranks fourth globally in terms of total
it says value of Natural Resources with
roughly 15 billion dollars in annual
output of potential assessed value that
could be as high as seven and a half
trillion dollars let me say this one
more time that could be as high as what
seven and a half trillion dollars so
guess what BlackRock and Larry think
think Bingo this is the type of a place
for us guys let's go in so for for you
to say well I don't think that's really
what's going on what happened with
everything with uh the movie the vice
what's the story about Donald Rumsfeld
or Dick Cheney or some of these guys
what deal you think they're doing behind
closed doors war war we make more money
let's get the contracts keep it going
guys this is great Halliburton this is
another the people that are following
the story a person very easily could
look at this and say I don't know if
this is like a conspiracy theory this is
CBC
the country ranks fourth globally in
terms of global assets value natural
resources roughly 15 billion dollars in
annual output with a potential assess
value potential assessed value of as
high seven and a half trillion dollars
you think Larry Fink who runs BlackRock
who's got over 10 trillion dollars of
assets under management only two
countries GDP is bigger than Larry
thinks companies total money on their
assets under management China and U.S
black rock is the third largest country
if you were to look at what they have
assets under management they're coming
in here saying guys come on guys what
are you doing you work for us here's
what you're going to do zelinski here's
what you're going to do Biden give this
guy that likes drugs and women and
prostitute a little bit of this to be
quiet what are we doing here this is too
much noise we're making guys stop it we
got to go make a few hundred billion
dollars you guys are playing small games
here let's go play the bigger games a
person who's not following it this way
you're either naive or you have so many
things going on in your life they don't
have time to follow this stuff and we
don't blame you at some point I didn't
my head was down working building my mic
making my money I didn't have time to
follow all of this stuff I was trying to
solve for my own thing but now when you
see this you realize what's really going
on behind Ukraine Bingo that's
essentially what I was saying I was like
we're talking 8 billion 8 million sorry
8 million that's nothing that's peanuts
but what you're saying BlackRock but all
this stuff but let me tell you let me
finish go ahead all I'm saying is
this is the real no nobody I know where
you're going let me just let me just
make it a point they can get to your
points
we all know that uh never let a crisis
go to waste yes okay what happened in
Europe after World War II they did
something called the Marshall Plan yeah
I think it was like 13 billion dollars
which in today's terms is 130 freaking
billion dollars what do you think is
going to happen in Ukraine after this
that the war is over that's essentially
what BlackRock is doing they're going to
rebuild Ukraine take all their assets
essentially what we did in Iraq take the
oil everything they're going to set up
money all that fun stuff what I'm saying
is ultimately this goes beyond Hunter
freaking Biden no I disagree okay I
disagree because
man people's Souls is for yourself for
not that much money
people people play Such different roles
in playing a pawn that you can make so
many deals for me are you kidding me the
fastest way for me to get the vice
president to do stuff is I got to pay
his son some money that's so cheap this
guy's a cheap buy you're nothing Epstein
158 8 million to a guy like this but you
know how big of a role he plays you know
the same meeting I said about Leon black
yep you want to have the same meeting
with uh uh Biden you don't think Biden's
had a similar meeting to say watch this
video with your son look what we got
that's your voice by the way of course
that's you by the way here's what you're
gonna do you're gonna keep giving
Ukraine money it ain't no zelinski
scaring the crap out of Biden to give
him money it's more people like Larry
Fink or more powerful people that are
running these State Street Vanguard you
know those guys are saying we're going
to put Ukraine money because we're
eventually going to go out there and
change everything about Ukraine because
they got up to seven and a half trillion
dollars of resources the fourth in the
world that's what we're doing your son's
got this don't get in our way Joe here's
what you're going to be saying to the
public no more screwing around we got
your back as long as you follow orders
again this is a speculation I am not
part of the CIA or underground whatever
that I notice it's pure opinion
speculation but let's go to the last one
here so both you're right and both he's
right all I'm saying is it's a complete
no it's not one or the other both of
them I actually fully agree with what
you're saying so that was ultimately my
point is there's bigger forces at play
100 and Hunter freaking body let's wrap
this up here with Mitch McConnell's
disturbing thing that happened yesterday
go ahead and play this clip with Mitch
McConnell he froze he froze it's
happened before but this one's
disturbing
can you put some audio around it
because he's being asked questions and
he's not responding
yeah we need audio Rob can you go to the
audio just go to the right side move the
thing to the right side
the back the back's got a pot okay guys
can you put audio on the back
can you raise it yeah by the way he was
just in the middle of giving a speech he
was he responding and then just froze
guys can we raise the audio
okay yeah he's not speaking that's why
there's no no no no no no no there's
there's background noise when you're
watching this because this doesn't tell
a story Rob let's find another clip it's
it's him standing like that go to my
account just go to my Twitter account
and and you'll see the one that I posted
he's literally Frozen and they
eventually had to move him and take him
to the side uh he had no idea what was
going back he had no he had it down
right there the one to the left the one
to the left click on the one to the left
the one to the left yeah
okay this one should have audio there
you go watch this
it's Joni it's right there what
Jonathan senator
varaso
watch how he walks
look he has no idea these are the people
making decisions for uh for us and our
future and our kids future you have the
other video of him being escorted away I
think it's right accident here's Senator
Johnson just you know tapping in
finishing the speech
yeah it was like the alien inside of his
head rebooted here's this one I'm
walking away
being escorted
Pat you see that he's how old how old is
he 81. 81 years old he's 81. uh Joe
Biden's 80. Pelosi's 83 Maxine Waters is
84. Chuck Grassley Is 89. Dianne
Feinstein is 90. she doesn't even know
who or where she is Carl Schwab 85
stores 92 the Robbie composite is that
like okay when people talk about term
let's if there is there no way to change
the fact that this is showing you like
they're falling apart in front of our
eyes John Stewart gave a Talk 11 months
ago right in front of it where he said
these [__] are 200 years old
they're like turtles they're here they
said guess what here's the thing that
both the left and the right agree on
yeah finally term limits guess what make
it work okay make it work to get term
limits in for this now that's not like
an overnight thing good luck getting
that in yeah uh because it's more
working the other way around you know
when you see stuff like this did you
know in 2010 uh uh they passed the law
so to allow corporations to have an open
checkbook on how much money they can
pretty much give to a campaign like do
you know how much money we all of a
sudden started putting into presidential
campaigns because it was a it was an
open shot have you seen this chart
before or not campaign Finance can you
send me that image that shows exactly
how much money was put into campaigns
from you know 2008 to 2012 16 2020. I'd
like to take a guess there's no cap
there was no cap no 2010 they opened it
up to say unlimited amount that you can
put in and now don't get me wrong so
Supreme Court I believe yeah it was a
Supreme Court ruling that if you can if
Brandon is watching Brandon I know you
are if you can just send me the pig for
me to show it to Rob uh uh uh let me see
if he's I know he's emailed it to me but
go ahead if you're watching this year
Tom you see McConnell react that way
what do you think about well I think
about the citizens united 2019 Citizens
United and that's what you all can go
Google and look up Supreme Court
decision uh where John Roberts wrote the
major already positioned it basically
took campaign Finance it used to be hey
check this box on your tax return if
you'd like a dollar one dollar to go to
the the presidential election fund
number one and then there's limits you
could only give so much each year or
each election there were limits citizens
united basically uncapped corporate and
it took everything away so it's all
special interests that control it and
what what is special interest and the
uncapped corporations want they got to
keep their puppets Pat and their puppets
are 90 year old mummies walking around
yeah by the way somehow citizens united
has a Google uh
what's it called when you can give
ratings Google ratings all that okay
yeah they're 1.8 that's right it's a
non-profit organization email Brandon
says emailed it to you so so basically
Pat the person with the most money
giving to the so these people wins it's
just the richest person gets the most
influence over who they want yeah I mean
that's insane and by the way listen to
the how they the logic of the Supreme
Court there's only one sentence you have
to listen to it right yeah the Court
held 5-4 that freedom of speech Clause
of the First Amendment prohibits the
government from restricting independent
expenditures for political campaigns by
corporations including non-profits labor
unions and associations what of that's
why the criticism of it is wait you used
freedom of speech you're classified
money tons
and by the way you know who wanted this
every member of Congress wanted this
because the special interest because I'm
an oil man you're a Pharma man you're an
agriculture man and you're a uh you're a
healthcare woman you're known by your
number one
and what you carry oh if you've ever
heard the um it's a a great phrase oh
you're Israel's guy on the hill and when
they say things like that oh yeah there
you go check this out this is how much
money presidential campaign financing 79
to 2020. it was only 197 million in 1979
80 then it went to 226 380 nothing crazy
346 478 612 891 Obama 1.769 billion
dollars and 1.46 1.529 Trump Biden look
at that if four billion dollars more
than the three previous elections
combined they spent everything they had
to terminate and fire Trump that's how
bad they wanted to get rid of them so
corporations came together and said
listen Open checkbook man here's some
money let's get rid of this guy this
guy's draining a swamp and we can no
longer do our deals that we were doing
this guy making our life a little bit
hard boom look how
there's never been a greater increase on
wanting to either elect somebody or get
rid of somebody than Trump that's a
great look at look at Obama Obama raised
that kind of money because it was a
dream it was the first time in U.S
history man we want to see this look at
the second one he dropped off he's the
only guy that for re-election his money
dropped off that's not a reflection of
Obama being a bad thing it's just the
fact that they really really wanted him
to win the first Samurai but they really
really yeah what a great point
before Trump uh Clinton what was the
closest presidential race prior to that
it was Bush yeah 2000 Gore Bush 612
million dollars was spent yeah
612. well we all know they used to use
the b word point they used to use the b
word when they're printed money billions
now it's all about the trillions
it was 2019 by the way citizens united
Supreme Court decision 2019. boom well
it's no wonder if you just follow the
money we just talked about it the other
day on the podcast
five out of the top 10 richest counties
in the country are all in what city
Washington DC watch all the money right
all the lobbyist money it's all the
campaign Finance money it's all going
there but back to Mitch McConnell
because how this whole thing started
look obviously the guy's not well you
know and generally I'm not a Mitch
McConnell fan but I hope he's doing well
time to step aside you know the only
answer to term limits right because
everyone wants term limits but you know
you know who who needs to vote on term
limits uh the Congress people they're
not going to do it so the only answer to
that is actually voting these incapable
vegetables out of office so it's
incumbent on the constituents
constituents people love it to vote
something like this up so someone in
Kentucky was like yep I want six more
years of McConnell and this is what you
get
oh my God frozen popsicle sticks well
it's it's almost like the alien in him
was like rebooting like yeah we didn't
even get into the alien story there's a
lot of things we can we we need three
hours
two hours about like five minutes we are
at the end of the podcast we covered a
lot of story great job gents great job
team in the back thank you rob gang uh
for those of you that
um are VIP tickets I think sold front
row to meet vivec I think we got a
couple of the premiums left and a couple
generals left that's happening next
Friday here here is it next yeah
live public so if you haven't yet
registered there's a couple generals
left VIP did sell out so for those that
wanted to meet them that's not available
but you can still be in there with vivec
this will be the beginning of many
others will be doing uh in that room we
have some special ones we're working on
that's not going to be a thousand
dollars I just want to prep you for some
of the other ones we'll be doing get
ready to open up your checkbooks to meet
some of these guys but uh we're excited
to have you guys here next this week if
you want to get registered either go to
5990live.com or text award podcast to
310-340-1132 again text award podcast to
three one zero
340-1132 have a great weekend everybody
we will do this again next week take
care bye bye bye
David here from Valentine and pbd
podcast look once a year we host a
conference called The Vault conference
it's our Super Bowl where 3 000
entrepreneurs CEOs executive sales
people from around the world come
together to spend three and a half days
together from August 30th to September
2nd at the Diplomat Resort in Miami to
learn how to scale their business how to
identify their next 5 10 15 moves who to
recruit next who to go raise their money
from how to raise Capital how to
properly skill culture retention higher
fire all of those things and much more
and we do that over a span of three and
a half days and the reason why it's a
very important season to attend a
conference like this the following
reason today there's three different
types of people they're scared they're
those that are content and the Obsessed
the scared they don't want to do
anything because they're worried about
what's going to happen in the economy
they're going to take a big hit the
content they're walking on saying life
is pretty okay I don't need to do
anything else and then there's the
obsessed because they see a massive
opportunity today so imagine spending
three and a half days with three
thousand obsessed people that want to
grow in a season like this imagine how
much you can run from just those
relationships and networks so on top of
the people that are going to be
attending at this event this is probably
the best lineup we'll ever have out of
all conference Tom Brady seven time
Champion I'll be interviewing him he'll
be at the Vault conference Mike Tyson
will gudara the gentleman who ran the
restaurant 11 Madison New York that went
from a regular restaurant to a one
Michelin star two Michelin star three
Michelin stars and eventually the number
one restaurant in the world he's going
to talk about how they treat their
customers so look if you've not
registered yeah this is my
recommendation to you I never went to
conferences when I was coming up by
myself I always went with a spouse with
a business partner or running mate
because I only have a lens on what I see
every night afterwards we would sit
there and say what was your biggest
takeaway so get yourself your spouse
your partner your running mate
registered to come spend three and a
half days with us at the Diplomat Resort
in Miami from August 30th to September
2nd I will see you there
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]